[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute mache ich einen Hundekuchen für den Yoshi.
Denn der wurde heute zwei.
[Tröte]
Und
ja, ein Hundekuchen.
Dafür brauchen wir
450 Gramm/Milliliter Wasser,
eine Tasse Basmati-Reis,
fünf Esslöffel Joghurt,
ein paar Leckerlis
und einen kleinen Löffel Kokosfett
und eine Karotte.
[Musik]
Also jetzt kochen wir erst mal den Reis.
Dafür benötigen wir einen Topf.
Soll ich den nehmen
oder den?
Ich würde den kleineren nehmen, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja. Ich glaube, der kleinere reicht.
>> SAMIRA: Dann tun wir da jetzt das Wasser rein.
Dann tun wir jetzt den Basmati-Reis dazu
und
lassen den Reis kochen.
Ich habe keine kleinere gefunden.
>> JOSH: Das macht nichts.
>> SAMIRA: Jetzt schneide ich die Karotte oder Möhre
mit dem Damastmesser.
Die ist auch schon gewaschen.
Also mit den Zutaten
müsst ihr zuerst den Arzt fragen
oder wenn ihr es schon wisst
– weil manche Hunde vertragen die Sachen nicht.
Und als Topping könnt ihr dann eben
halt auch Leberwurst
oder andere Wurst, die der Hund verträgt,
eben benutzen.
[Musik]
Aber das ist praktisch.
So zwei auf zwei.
Das waren sogar drei auf drei.
Und jetzt habe ich es doppelt durchgeschnitten.
So. Okay.
Jetzt nehmen wir uns eine Schüssel
von hier
und tun da
alle Zutaten rein, die wir brauchen.
Jetzt nehme ich mir hier den Teigschaber
und nehme eben das Kokosfett oder eben das Kokosöl raus.
Dann tu ich die Hundeleckerlis dazu.
Ihr könnt da Hundeleckerlis nach Wahl benutzen.
Also es ist eigentlich egal.
Wir haben so kleinere genommen.
Also
ich finde, kleinere sind immer besser.
Und eben das Wichtige dran ist,
weil wir es ja gerade für den Yoshi machen,
– ihr macht es bestimmt für einen anderen Hund –
dass sie eben klein sind
und dass sie Hundeleckerlis sind
und keine Katzenleckerlis.
>> JOSH: Und wenn man es für die Katze macht?
>> SAMIRA: Ja,
dann müsste man auf jeden Fall andere Produkte benutzen.
Weil die vertragen ja Milch nicht so arg
und auch keinen Joghurt, also Milchprodukte eben.
Weil das ist ja eher schädlich für die
und die bekommen ja auch Durchfall.
Josh, du hattest eine Katze.
Sag was dazu.
>> JOSH: Oh, das ist schon lange her.
Das weiß ich leider nicht genau.
>> SAMIRA: Okay, egal.
>> JOSH: Aber das wird schon stimmen, was du sagst.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, das habe ich von der Sarah gelernt
und von meiner Mama.
Es sieht natürlich sehr appetitlich aus.
Also das Kokosfett oder eher gesagt Kokosöl
benutze ich,
weil der Hund dann eben einen besseren Mundgeruch hat.
Geruch?
Mund – Atem.
Ja, so in der Art eben.
Und man kann da auch gerne
Basilikum oder Minze reinmachen.
Wie geht es unserem Reis?
Er köchelt gerade.
Okay. So.
Jetzt müssen wir erst mal eine halbe Stunde warten
wegen dem Reis.
Und jetzt tun wir die Masse,
solange der Reis kocht,
in den Kühlschrank.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich die Masse aus dem Kühlschrank rausgeholt.
Und jetzt gebe ich den Reis hinzu.
Der ist jetzt noch lauwarm
und, ja,
schmeckt gut.
Okay. Das reicht erst mal.
Also dieses Rezept ist für zwei Personen,
also zwei Hunde.
Boah, weißt du was?
Ich knete das jetzt einmal mit meiner Hand.
So. Ich habe meine Hände gewaschen.
Und jetzt knete ich diese Masse durch,
was sich eklig anfühlt.
Also riechen tut sie etwas komisch
wegen den Hundeleckerlis.
Also es könnte sein,
dass ihr noch ein bisschen mehr Jogurt benötigt.
Aber
ich finde, es geht auch so.
Ich tu jetzt noch mal ein bisschen rein.
Es ist jetzt sogar schon eklig, Reis anzufassen.
Also es kann sehr viel werden.
Es ist auch für vier Hundepersonen.
>> JOSH: Oh!
>> SAMIRA: Vielleicht auch für 20.
Oder 10.000.
Ich wasche kurz mein Hände.
Dann mache ich Frischhaltefolie drüber.
Dann kann man auch sicher sein, dass es nicht klebt.
Weil das klebt noch etwas.
Und es ist inzwischen auch schon abgekühlt.
Oha! Das legt sich voll auf mein Gesicht drauf.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Ein kurzer Lachanfall,
aber ein sehr kurzer.
So. Und jetzt fülle ich da die Masse rein.
Also ich habe sie gerade eben,
wie ihr sehen konntet,
die beiden Schüsseln
mit Frischhaltefolie umwickelt,
dass man eben auch sicher sein kann,
dass es eben nicht klebt.
Und so eine Portion ist eben für den Yoshi gedacht.
Also er ist ja auch nicht so groß.
Aber,
wenn es dann zu groß ist,
– es kommt eben auf den Hund drauf an –
kann man ja auch die Hälfte machen.
Das kann man ja in der App bestimmen.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Machst du da einen Hundegrößenumrechner rein?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Und dann gibt man da die Rassen ein,
Golden Retriever, Rottweiler,
Chihuahua.
[Musik]
Also bei mir sind jetzt eineinhalb rausgekommen so,
ein bisschen mehr.
So.
Ja, aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht den ganzen Reis benutzt.
Ja.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kommt das für fünf Minuten in die Kühltruhe.
Also es ist jetzt wie beim Sandkuchenmachen.
Ich stürze jetzt den Kuchen.
Oh!
Und jetzt
nehme ich noch als Deko
Hundekekschen.
Ich glaube, Yoshi isst nur die Hundekekse runter.
[Musik]
So. Okay. Ich hole jetzt Yoshi.
Aber davor gehe ich aufs Klo.
Yoshi, hier!
Hier.
>> ELA: Yoshi!
Dann mal hopp!
>> SAMIRA: Feiner Yoshi!
Äh!
Josh, kann ich?
>> JOSH: Ja, du kannst.
>> SAMIRA: Ich komme ein bisschen.
Das Leckerli kommt hier obendrauf.
Und...
Alles Gute zum Geburtstag.
>> ELA: Alles Gute zum...
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Der pult da die Leckerlis raus.
Du schlauer Hund!
Also es scheint, dass Yoshi der Kuchen schmeckt
und die Leckerlis am meisten.
Besonders wichtig ist es auch,
dass man da keine Gewürze reinmacht
oder eben kein Salz oder Pfeffer eben reinmacht.
Und
ihr könnt es auf jeden Fall ausprobieren.
Yoshi scheint es zu schmecken.
Und ihr könnt da auch gerne
anderes Gemüse noch reinmachen
oder eben als Karotte was anderes reinmachen.
Und...
Also, wenn es euch gefallen hat,
dann lasst gern ein Abo da.
>> JOSH: Gut.
>> SAMIRA: Und
bis zum nächsten Mal mit einem anderen Rezept.
Wenn es dir geschmeckt hat, sag High five
– gib mir High five.
Fein!
[Musik]